last year I made a video where I had my
co-workers eat an orange in the shower
and that was a lot of fun I don't think
any lives were changed from that
experience this year I was going through
the internet and I found yet another
shower trend apparently people like to
get in the shower and drink a beer
we are back drinking and eating stuff in
the showers I know nothing about the
shower beer situation you just invited
me and I said yes I've experienced some
form of this of crying in my shower
drinking a bottle of wine I think having
a beer in the shower it's a little
stupid but there's nothing wrong with
being a little stupid why not what else
are we supposed to do while we're here
on this way
these are alleged benefits drinking
beers and shower can promote creativity
and productivity and held a drink relax
and decrease stress
okay I'm gonna [ __ ] drink in the show
the extra release of dopamine from the
shower added with the initial benefits
of the one drink a day philosophy can
actually help reduce stress a lot all
right so let's see how this experiment
goes drinking drinking it all right the
smell seems strong something about maybe
being in the shower or the steam I don't
that was very pleasant
[Music]
[Music]
this is fun
[Music]
I don't know what the hell I'm doing
it's so weird
do you smell fear is it like to begin
again we're showering and to the show it
seems like incredible waste of water
right there someone inside asking for
some turn to the shower here
only male to their community please that
means that I speak okay I can't hold my
highest I wonder how my dear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was fun that's cool I'm feeling I'm
feeling a little tipsy actually and I'm
really enjoying this water running over
here sure yeah I was really stressed out
yes would do this again as far as a
day-to-day sort of deal probably not
you feel a little come on the show every
once in a while and it's delightful
I just don't think anything came with it
and that beer is good but did I enjoy my
time this had a nice time with my shower
beer feel a little tipsy that's nice I
don't feel like either part of the
experience was Heidi's by the other like
I don't feel like the beer was better
than normal and I don't feel like my
showers was better than normal
it's so relaxing I guess it felt like I
was ready to dance I cleaned my whole
apartment
[Music]